so I got to The Improv the other day I
was doing a show there I don't remember
what it was but I got there and I did
the show and when I got there I got off
stage and some lady came up to me
afterwards and she said hi and I was
like oh this is a French film you know
why I knew she was French before she
even started talking is because she was
uh one of those kinds of [__] people
that you think is ugly and then in like
three seconds you're like oh no they're
not ugly this is actually one of the
most attractive people I've ever seen in
my life
you know what I'm talking about French
people will really kill you with that
[__] a French woman at that will come up
to you and she'll be like hi and you'll
be like I don't know I don't have the
time because I was just and then you
look at her and you'll and you'll
immediately just like the you'll focus
in on it and you'll be like oh the nose
threw me off but you're a 10.
oh those teeth look crowded as [__] but
in a way it works for you oh too much
gel in your hair and I like the natural
[__] but baby isn't that just your style
right
you make me want to be a citizen of the
blue white and red or whatever their
flag is I have no idea because I'm a
dumb [__]
but still she come up to me and she was
like hi
she was so French that when she was
talking it already felt like she was
touching my face
and I said yeah hi I thought you was
ugly quickly realized one of the most
attractive human beings in my life
okay all good and by the way I didn't
say sexy I didn't say good looking
there's a there's a huge difference
between good looking sexy hot and the
just plain old attractive
right
do you know what I'm talking about
with those striking features because if
you're attractive you can get away with
having a [__] bonker's ugly nose or a
weird mouth or maybe your lips don't
match your face I'm secretly talking
about me
but you can get away with being
attractive right because there's like
this aura about you
this French charm
I don't remember what she was wearing
but it was all one piece of fabric right
it wasn't pants in a shirt it could have
been a sundress it could have been a
jumpsuit it was all one piece of fabric
I have no idea
and she was just like hi and I said oh
hi how you doing and she said I'm a big
fan do you mind if I take a picture with
you and I said sure why not
and we took a picture and she said I
just want to tell you
um when you were gone for a long time it
was amazing it is amazing you came back
I really we miss you you know you have
fans out there and I said oh thank you
very much and she and then I went to go
take a picture with someone else and
then she popped by like it was the
sequel right like we shot a whole French
film it was over and then she popped by
and wanted to say something else like it
was a sequel and she said I can I also
say something else for you and I said
well sure she was nice enough and I and
she said I just want to say that
everybody has their problems and it is
okay and we don't judge you for that and
we don't care we are your fans
but you look skinny
I said huh
she said I want to make sure you're
healthy because you look skinny
and I said oh no I'm I'm good I'm a
Beefcake you know it's crazy like my
shoulders go on for days and night but
she broke me dude you know like I was I
wanted to go into that mode like no it's
fine look sweetheart they they shoot the
Lord of the Rings on my back I mean
Hollywood's on location right here and
she says
you're skinny and I was like
and it kind of broke me a little bit you
know it was like a real moment she was
like I hope you're healthy and you're
eating okay but you look skinny
and I was like well well thanks for
caring you know
and then I walked out and I told my
friend what the [__] happened and he was
like my friend is so [__] he's like
so boring he was just like well you know
what it is is a lot of the time you know
it's a real like middle uh it's it's
European it's a very European thing to
and I was like yeah bro I get I didn't
want to do this whole thing okay
just it's some chick called me skinny
and it's fine dude I got lost in a
French moment that's it I got lost in a
French [__] and I had a French
Connection and this [__] chick told
me that I was skinny and now I got now I
got to worry about doing some [__]
dips and chin-ups man
I mean I'm like sorry strong guys of
course I'm like to the Limit with my
[__] striations but this chick just
broke me immediately by having a moment
man
that's that French Connection man only
French people could really break you
like that honestly